[Música]
Bienvenidos a directo con 27 el programa
en el que les traemos las noticias más
relevantes de la Cumbre climática en
Egipto hoy el cuarto día ha estado
dedicado a las finanzas Esta es la
discusión central de las negociaciones
pues es donde se definen los puntos más
difíciles sobre qué dinero destinar para
combatir la crisis climática uno de los
anuncios más esperados fue el que hizo
hoy John carry el enviado especial de la
Casa Blanca para el clima el
estadounidense dio a conocer la creación
de una alianza para que las empresas más
contaminantes ayuden a financiar la
transición a las energías limpias
conectamos con Shake en Egipto donde
están nuestras enviadas especiales María
Clara calle y marina Colorado María
Clara cuéntenos en qué consiste el
anuncio de Carrie
Pues todo esto en lo que consiste es en
el lanzamiento del acelerador de
transición energética algo que se creó
en una alianza entre Estados Unidos y
las fundaciones rockefeller y besos
Earth entonces en qué consiste la idea
es que las compañías que son más
contaminantes financien de manera
voluntaria los proyectos en países en
desarrollo que le apuestan a una
transición a las energías limpias es
decir que las compañías privadas entren
al mercado de carbono pero este mercado
tiene otra cara Antonio Gutiérrez el
secretario general de la ONU también
dijo aquí en la Cup 27 que no se puede
caer en un lavado de cara del mercado de
carbono ya que por ejemplo las empresas
que financian combustibles fósiles no
pueden hablar de que logran la
neutralidad de carbono y por otro lado
advirtió que existen múltiples criterios
para medir Cómo se da esta neutralidad
de la advertencia de guterres John Kerry
dijo que había hablado con el secretario
general y que él apoyaba el acelerador
impulsado por Estados Unidos y es que
este acelerador tendrá ciertos criterios
Como por ejemplo no podrán participar
compañías que se dedican o que no tengan
la promesa de lograr las cero emisiones
netas a 2050 y en un principio tampoco
podrían participar las compañías
petroleras sin embargo esto todavía no
se sabe totalmente lo que sí que se
conoce es que el 5% de estos créditos de
carbono se dedicarán a la adaptación y a
la resiliencia y por otra parte ya hay
algunos interesados como chile Nigeria o
las compañías Microsoft y Pepsi Cola y
estos países no son los únicos en
Colombia cada vez se escucha más la
propuesta del gobierno para cambiar la
deuda internacional
climáticas que tengan que ver con la
adaptación y la mitigación al respecto
nuestra compañera Marina Colorado habló
con la ministra de medio ambiente de
Colombia Susana muham Muchísimas gracias
Susana muham por estar con nosotros
ministra de medio ambiente de Colombia
hoy es el Día de las finanzas uno de los
días más importantes en estas Cumbres
climáticas normalmente y Colombia ha
propuesto un sistema de intercambio de
deuda por créditos de carbono
explíquenos en qué consiste el modelo
Bueno lo que hemos solicitado es que
como política internacional se le deje
más espacio fiscal a los países hoy
Colombia por ejemplo tiene que pagar un
porcentaje importante de su presupuesto
en deuda externa y realmente con la
crisis económica Pues estamos viendo las
finanzas del Estado apretadas para
responder a la adaptación y a la
mitigación climática Si queremos avanzar
en los tiempos que necesitamos No
necesitamos solo cooperación
internacional sino que nuestros estados
se fortalezcan y puedan responder por
eso el presidente ha lanzado de la
iniciativa de canje de deuda por acción
climática pero a una escala que no se ha
hecho anteriormente esto se ha hecho
antes pero a escala de proyectos muy
concretos aquí queremos hacerlo a una
escala global como un pacto político que
le permita a los Estados tener capacidad
de respuesta que se ha visto limitada
por la situación económica y creen que
los países que han prestado ese dinero
estarán dispuestos es factible este
modelo Sí con los bancos multilaterales
tiene que ser una política Internacional
del fondo monetario internacional
estamos ya interacción con el Banco
Mundial con el banco interamericano de
desarrollo Porque si queremos acelerar
la acción que realmente es un progreso
económico también debemos generar este
este proceso y yo creo que es un pedido
de poner a la población en la mitad de
la negociación climática en este momento
Colombia tiene 400.000 damnificados por
el invierno vamos a tener que
reconstruir regiones enteras años y años
de inversión social se pierden en un
desastre climático y si no aceleramos la
acción esto después va a ser impagable
entonces tanto en adaptación como
mitigación la acción es urgente si no
queremos realmente un colapso no
solamente de la economía sino realmente
de la civilización pues muchísimas
gracias Susana muhammad ministra de
ambiente del gobierno de Colombia
seguimos con ustedes en Bogotá esto es
todo en directo cop27 desde
era marinada
Egipto les recordamos que directo con 27
se emite de lunes a sábado a las 12 y 15
horas de Bogotá quito y Lima hasta el 18
de noviembre cuando se clausura esta
Cumbre ustedes quédense aquí en la
pantalla de Flash 24
[Música]